meet the fellows event so we have five
talks given by fellows in the logic and
AI for databases program the first talk
is by Wong who tell us about relation
prog thank
you okay so uh uh by myself I recently
graduated from udub uh working with denu
right now sem joining UCLA uh next year
as a assistant
professor and uh I think we've seen a
lot of math a lot of words today so I'm
going to begin with a small history
lesson
right so about a 100 years ago uh
computer science started with a dream uh
this guy David hit uh wanted to do this
thing which is understanding the world
with the reason right this is by the end
of the first world war so people were
going a little crazy so uh uh hbert
thought that we could benefit from from
some
reasoning and because Hubert is a
mathematician or was a ma mathematician
to him the world means math and then
reason means logic so this was the
well-known hus program which is trying
to uh build this formal Foundation that
based on Logic for
mathematics so soon after not very long
after uh these two people came and uh
Kuro and and oning basically uh came
with results saying that you cannot do
this right so first of all we have the
inconen theorems of gudo saying that you
cannot have a uh formal system that's
both consistent and expressive enough to
to express
arithmetics and then Ty also came along
with his uh hting problem which show
that is a negative resolution to the
anid problem saying that you cannot have
a machine that just proves all of math
uh if you just leun it so on the surface
this was kind of a blow uh to our dream
of understanding world with reason but I
think this is actually a really
fantastic thing right because uh from
the result we got computers which are
really magical machines uh that make our
dreams come true and then make our
wildest dreams and something that we
didn't even dare to dream of come true
so in a sense uh we instead of
understanding the world we reducing Mass
to logic uh we're able to to change the
world with
logic uh but not so quick right in the
beginning the way we program these
machines are are really painful right so
these are uh some of the the pioneers of
programmers working on uh the first
computer called eniac and they were
literally patching the cables with with
their hands in order to to put in the B
bed patterns uh in in terms of uh
programs right and then later on we got
a little better technology so we have
the punch cars where you can enter
numbers uh which uh basically represent
assembly code uh and it was not until
the 1960s that that we have this
cambering explosion of pro programming
languages that really increase our
productivity so here's kind of a sample
of all of the different flavors uh of PL
that came out around the time of 60 and
70s but what we're here to talk about
today is not any of these pictures uh
it's ideas of just using logic you know
we're going back to to hus uh program
can we just use logic uh to express what
we want to compute and we want to tell
the computer to
do uh and then indeed uh we can and then
so people came up with some programming
languages one is prologue uh on the
other end of spectrum is actually SQL or
SQL uh that are based on this logical
Foundation uh that let us Pro programmer
computers so these are these languages
are on kind of two extremes of the
spectrum
so CLE is immensely successful so if you
have a smartphone it's running SLE right
now this is running s right now this
running signle right now so it's
everywhere it runs the world literally
uh and then it works because it's really
really fast and then you know tech
people were addicted to efficiency right
so on one end with Str this really fast
but it's really Limited in uh Express
this so the On The Other Extreme uh
prologue is a the complete language
meaning that you can basically write any
program you want to write so it's really
expressive uh but as uh a drawback um
you know it kind of suffers in terms of
efficiency as compared to
SQL so uh one of my uh research project
is on this uh picking this sweet spot uh
in the spectrum between expressiveness
and efficiency uh and then with designed
language card data logo uh which is an
extension of this log with the power
saring
so on the expressive end uh we took some
great ideas uh from before so we have
the recursive rules for the from the
data law language and then we have the
saring which allows us to express
computation over a very rich data data
type so this uh allows us to to express
a lot of uh really uh useful computation
like Matrix algebra linear algebra uh
and then shortest path algorithms over
graphs so we have recursion and
aggregation at the same
time so on the other uh consideration
for efficiency right so we also look at
the algorithms for the relational Joy so
Joy is really important because that's
basically uh the operator we use to run
any databas quy uh so it's a
generalization of functional composition
as relation is a generation of of
functions so this really the bread and
butter of relational databases
and then we also look at ways to
optimize deogo programs so this means
that you give me some really high level
intuitive program and then I will
rearrange operations to make sure that
uh it it runs very
efficiently uh and then along outside of
the context of kind of database and
datalog I also work with with my
colleagues in programming languages uh
and then we developed this idea of using
tree autometer uh aliz programs so I'm
going to go into a little bit more a bit
more detail on that very
soon so uh here's a kind of sample of a
problems that I'm interested in so I
think some of these are open some of
these are might be not I'm not a
theorist so I don't know so if you tell
me someone some of these are already
solved that will make me really happy
where if it's not if it's open that will
make you very happy because you can
solve
it so uh one of the example is that that
uh look at this uh it just a finite
state automon right so let's look at the
string case so this is a string string
automon and if we just treat this
automon as a graph so ignore the labels
on the edges and the states so we we
treat each state as a vertex and then we
treat each transition as an edge uh then
suppose we want to find uh the shortest
path from the starting stage uh to the
acceptance state right so it's right
here we can go through here to
here and if we do this for some kind of
automaton and then we think of this path
uh as as having cost to each symbol that
essentially lets us extract the cheapest
string that's represented by the by the
language right so that's a string case
uh and then in the in the string case we
have the autom as a graph so over sour B
is is it's pretty fast uh you know time
work pretty fast but for programs we
actually need the So-Cal tree automet so
these are generalizations of of string
automaton to accept a language of trees
in inside strings and then over there
the problem basically becomes we want to
find the cheapest tree cheapest or the
lowest weighted tree represented by the
automaton and then over there we
basically need to solve this shortest
hyper paath problem
uh and then as far as I know there has
been some early algorithms actually by
by Donal K solving this in uh um in
pretty efficient time uh but then when
you have kind of P considering of hyper
AES there's there's a question of do you
double count uh you
know an ed do used twice or do you only
count it once right so basically one
problem is short path on short hyper
path on tree autom
uh so another kind of short path flavor
problem uh is the so-call alra path
problem uh and I think it's really
elegant because of a very general
problem right so the input is a graph
which is vertex and vertices and edges
and then two uh sync and Target um uh
vertices uh in the graph and then what
we want to do is to find a regular
expression over their edges in the graph
such that the reg expression represents
uh all possible path from s to V uh in
the graph right so once you find this
reg expression this really symbolic
expression you can evaluate it over
different searings to solve uh you know
short power problems and then some some
kind of flow
problems uh so uh there's been
algorithms uh one of these are is by by
B tarent saying that if your graph is
soal reducible that you can do this in
almost linear time so Alpha here is the
reverse AC function right so I'm
interested in saying that uh
like not a lot of database graphs are
actually reducible so on these uh graphs
can we get some property so that we can
also get efficient uh efficient
algorithms like
this yeah
the for reducible graphs uh I'm not sure
yeah but it's basically lar so I don't
think you
much uh okay and then here's a pretty
ster question so find the sparse
homomorphic image of a of a hyph so homm
is it's kind of standard it's a mapping
from vertices to vertices such that if
there's an edge between two vertic in
the source you should have an edge in
the uh in the Target graph right so here
we have a tradeoff of you know we want
to to uh we want the image to be as
small as possible but we also want it to
to be sparse right so you can always map
everything to you know uh just uh like a
single vertex with a sou Loop so you
just map all of the vertices to the to
the same vertex and this is fine but
it's really dense right it's really
small but really dense so we want to
find this uh uh this sweet spot uh in in
the trof
space uh okay so going back to to hbert
uh he tried to understand the world with
logic uh but I invite you uh to to uh
change your world with log logic with me
thank
you thank you um any
[Applause]
questions